did you see Trump's rally last night
nope me neither
pretty says some pretty bad stuff about
us really that doesn't sound like him
I heard he said we're all no talent
lowlife lost souls well that's not right
that's Conan Donald Trump
the real estate guy who sells steaks
he's president yeah
well that was last night's hold open
from Stephen Colbert and Jimmy Fallon
the first time that both of their
late-night shows ran the exact same Opie
the idea was Stephens
he called Jimmy yesterday and The
Tonight Show hoes quickly agreed Jimmy
Kimmel by the way is on vacation totally
off the grid but Conan O'Brien also
agreed right away to join in the entire
open was shot yesterday afternoon and I
think it's so clever Bravo to all three
of them now make go Stephen Colbert when
I first heard it John didn't you think
that sounds like Stephen Colbert to me
make America Comedy unite again yeah
that's right they changed the whole
opening to Colbert show is the joke
continues through so it's yeah it's
worth going to take a little look-see
because it's very well done